This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The night of February 27, 2010, Luis Enriquez was getting home from his job at a lumber factory in Constantinio, Chile. Ah, that's from the morning. It was around 3 in the morning. I was watching TV with my wife and a neighbor, and all of a sudden, we started feeling the earth shake. And it was just getting stronger and stronger and stronger to the point that we couldn't stand up.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2010年2月27日晚，路易斯·恩里克斯下班回到智利孔斯蒂图西翁的木材厂家中。啊，那是早上的事了。当时大约是凌晨3点。我和妻子还有一位邻居正在看电视，突然，我们开始感觉到大地在震动。震感越来越强烈，越来越剧烈，以至于我们都无法站立。
Producer Sam Greenspan, translating for Luis. Luis was in an earthquake, a bad one. When the shaking finally stopped, he was relieved to see that his wife and their two kids were all fine, but Luis knew they were still in danger. Because in Chile, everyone is taught from childhood that after an earthquake hits, the first thing you do is get to higher ground. Which is what Luis and his family did. They got in their car and they sped to the top of a nearby hill.
制片人萨姆·格林斯潘为路易斯担任翻译。路易斯经历了一场地震，一场严重的地震。当震动终于停止时，他很欣慰地看到妻子和两个孩子都平安无事，但路易斯知道他们仍处于危险之中。因为在智利，每个人从小就被教导，地震发生后，第一件事就是往高处跑。这就是路易斯和家人所做的。他们上了车，飞速驶向附近的一座小山顶。
From its peak, Luis could look down from the hillside to where the river Maule meant the Pacific Ocean. You could see it happening. You could see it super clearly. You could see the waves coming into the city. The earthquake that Luis is describing was tremendous. a magnitude 8.8, the second biggest at the world had seen in the past 50 years. The Quake and ensuing tsunami completely crushed the seaside town of Constitucione Chile, where Louise lives. By the time it was over, more than 500 people were dead,
从山顶上，路易斯可以俯瞰莫莱河汇入太平洋的地方。你可以看到这一切正在发生。你可以看得非常清楚。你可以看到海浪涌入城市。路易斯所描述的地震非常巨大，震级为8.8级，是过去50年来世界经历过的第二大地震。地震和随之而来的海啸彻底摧毁了路易斯居住的智利海滨小镇孔斯蒂图西翁。当一切结束时，已有500多人丧生，
and 80% of the city's buildings were ruined. As part of a relief effort, an architecture firm called Elemental was hired to create a master plan of the city's buildings were ruined. As part of a relief effort, an architecture firm called Elemental was hired to create a master plan for the city, which included new housing for people displaced in the disaster. But the structures that Elemental delivered were a radical and somewhat controversial approach
城市80%的建筑被毁。作为救灾工作的一部分，一家名为Elemental的建筑公司被聘请为该市制定总体规划，其中包括为灾民提供新的住房。但Elemental交付的结构是一种激进且颇具争议的住房方案。
towards housing. They gave people half a house. A picture, a simple two-story home with a pitched roof, They gave people half a house. PICTURE A SIMPLE TWO STORY HOME WITH A PITCHED ROOF A square with a triangle on top, basically how a kid would draw a house. Only in these, there's a wall that runs down the middle, from the peak of the roof, all the way to the ground, splitting the house in half. One side of the house is finished, and the other side. And the other side.
他们给了人们半套房子。想象一下，一栋简单的两层楼房，带有坡屋顶，一个正方形上面顶着一个三角形，基本上就是孩子画房子的样子。只是在这些房子里，有一堵墙从屋顶的最高处一直延伸到地面，把房子一分为二。房子的一侧是完工的，而另一侧……另一侧。
The other side is a completely empty space. There's a roof and an exterior wall, but the rest is just an open void. The architecture firm behind these houses, the Santiago-based Elemental, has made a name for themselves building these half-a-homes, and not just as disaster relief either. Today, Elemental has done about 10 low-income housing projects across Chile, all designed so that the homes would be largely unfinished when the residents moved in. And the response from the architectural community has been immense. In 2016, the firm's founder, Alejandro Arravena, was awarded the Pritzker Prize, the top prize in architecture.
另一侧是一个完全空旷的空间。有一个屋顶和一堵外墙，但其余部分只是一个开放的空洞。这家位于圣地亚哥的建筑公司Elemental，因建造这些“半套房”而闻名，而且不仅仅是用于救灾。如今，Elemental在智利完成了大约10个低收入住房项目，所有项目的设计初衷都是让居民入住时房子大部分尚未完工。建筑界对此反响巨大。2016年，该公司的创始人亚历杭德罗·阿拉维纳获得了建筑界的最高奖项——普利兹克奖。
In their jury citation, the Pritzker Architecture Prize said that, quote, Alejandro Arravena epitomizes the revival of a more socially engaged architect, especially in his long-term commitment to tackling the global housing crisis and fighting for a better urban environment for all. This for building disaster victims and other poor people unfinished homes. To understand where these half-built houses came from, you have to understand them as an attempt to solve the problem of global urban migration. Over the past several decades, people the world over have been migrating from the countryside to cities. The draw of the city was creating this problem.
普利兹克建筑奖在评审团引文中称，引用如下：“亚历杭德罗·阿拉维纳是更具社会参与感的建筑师复兴的缩影，特别是在他长期致力于解决全球住房危机和为所有人争取更好的城市环境方面。”这指的是为灾民和其他贫困人口建造未完工的房屋。要理解这些半成品房屋的由来，你必须将其视为解决全球城市移民问题的一种尝试。在过去的几十年里，世界各地的人们一直在从农村向城市迁移。城市的吸引力造成了这个问题。
So, the result is squatting. This is George Cotoni, an architect who grew up all around Latin America, mostly in El Salvador. George saw first-hand what happens when a population outgrows its supply of buildings. The housing deficit of San Salvador, the capital, was something about 10,000 units a year and growing. was something about 10,000 units a year and growing. The backlog of people that had no services, no, it was unbelievable. George wanted to help solve this problem, but I was struggling with how to make a house affordable.
所以，结果就是非法占地。这是乔治·科托尼，一位在拉丁美洲各地长大，主要在萨尔瓦多的建筑师。乔治亲眼目睹了当人口超过建筑供应量时会发生什么。圣萨尔瓦多（首都）的住房缺口大约每年1万套，而且还在增加。积压的人群没有服务，没有……这简直令人难以置信。乔治想帮助解决这个问题，但我一直在努力思考如何让房子变得负担得起。
In the 1970s, George heard about a new master's program at MIT. A program called Urban Settlement Design in Developing Countries. At MIT, George found a mentor and a professor named John F.C. Turner. So John F.C. Turner, a British urban planner, was spearheading this idea that people can build for themselves. In a 1972 essay called Housing as a Verb, Turner made the case that housing ought not be a static unit that is packaged and just handed over to people.
20世纪70年代，乔治听说麻省理工学院有一个新的硕士项目。一个名为“发展中国家城市住区设计”的项目。在麻省理工学院，乔治找到了一位导师，名叫约翰·F.C.特纳。约翰·F.C.特纳是一位英国城市规划师，他率先提出了“人们可以为自己建造”的理念。在1972年一篇名为《住房作为动词》的文章中，特纳提出，住房不应该是一个被打包好直接交给人们的静态单元。
Rather, housing should be conceived of as an ongoing project wherein residents are co-creators. And from this thesis, Turner helped promote an idea. This idea that was emerging, this sites and services idea. Sites and services, also sometimes called incremental building. It basically means instead of building people completed homes, governments should just build the key parts of a home that people have the hardest time building on their own,
相反，住房应该被视为一个持续进行的项目，居民是共同创造者。基于这一论点，特纳帮助推广了一个理念。这个正在兴起的理念，即“选址与服务”理念。选址与服务，有时也称为增量建筑。它基本上意味着，政府不应该为人们建造完整的房屋，而应该只建造人们自己最难建造的房屋关键部分，
like concrete foundations, insulation, plumbing, electrical wiring. And then get the government to provide services to those sites. Roads, drainage, sores, or pitilotrenes, whatever the case may be. Garbage collection, you've got to route your trucks to this schools. Thus, gradually over time, people start to turn their basic sites into suitable housing, with materials they source themselves on their own terms. What people have to donate of their own is labor, the cost of labor. And the cost of materials to expand. But in the end, they own what they build. It's their investment.
比如混凝土基础、隔热层、管道、电线。然后让政府为这些地点提供服务。道路、排水、污水处理或坑式厕所，视情况而定。垃圾收集，你必须让卡车开到这些地方。因此，随着时间的推移，人们开始用他们自己以自己的方式采购的材料，将他们的基本场地变成合适的住房。人们必须贡献的是劳动力，即劳动成本。以及扩建所需的材料成本。但最终，他们拥有自己建造的东西。这是他们的投资。
They have the ability. And governments cannot build as well as quickly in a way that makes sense to these households. Since finishing his studies at MIT in the 1970s, George has done these kinds of incremental building projects all over the world, in Latin America, Kenya, Indonesia, and these projects can take different forms. Sometimes it's just giving people a concrete pad with utility hookups. Sometimes it's just giving people a one-room house with a kitchen and bathroom and the expectation that they'll build extra rooms onto it.
他们有能力。政府无法以对这些家庭有意义的方式快速建造出同样好的房子。自20世纪70年代在麻省理工学院完成学业以来，乔治在世界各地，包括拉丁美洲、肯尼亚、印度尼西亚，都做过这类增量建筑项目，这些项目可以采取不同的形式。有时只是给人们提供一个带有公用设施接口的混凝土垫。有时只是给人们提供一个带厨房和浴室的一居室，并期望他们会在上面加盖额外的房间。
It sounds odd, but believe me, it works. These ideas that George Cotoni and his contemporaries at MIT pioneered, that governments can support people building for themselves and then let them own what they build, began to spread through the developing world. And so when the architecture firm Elemental got their first commission to do low income housing in Chile, they took the ideas from incremental housing as points of departure. Yeah, absolutely. We didn't create the idea, actually.
这听起来很奇怪，但相信我，它行得通。乔治·科托尼和他在麻省理工学院的同僚们开创的这些理念——即政府可以支持人们为自己建造，然后让他们拥有自己建造的东西——开始在发展中国家传播。因此，当建筑公司Elemental接到他们在智利建造低收入住房的第一个委托时，他们将增量住房的理念作为出发点。是的，绝对是。其实我们并没有创造这个想法。
We import that to make something that can be improved by time. This is Juan Ignacio Cereda, one of the principal architects at Elemental. Cereda told me that in 2002, Elemental got a commission to build 100 units of low-income housing in a city in northern Chile called Iquique. And they had to deliver it on a tight budget. $7,500 unit. With only $7,500 allocated per household, the most straightforward and cost-effective way to house all 100 families was to cram everyone
我们引入它是为了创造出一种可以随着时间推移而改进的东西。这是胡安·伊格纳西奥·塞雷达，Elemental的首席建筑师之一。塞雷达告诉我，2002年，Elemental接到委托，要在智利北部城市伊基克建造100套低收入住房。他们必须在紧张的预算下交付。每套7500美元。由于每个家庭只有7500美元的预算，安置所有100个家庭最直接且最具成本效益的方法就是把每个人都塞进
into big block style apartments. When they hear, what about blocks? They said, if you dare to propose a block, we start a hunger strike, because it's the worst thing ever. According to one Ignacio Serra, the community threatened to hunger strike because an apartment block would be extremely limiting.
大块头式的公寓里。当他们听到“公寓楼”时，他们说，如果你敢提议建公寓楼，我们就绝食抗议，因为那是世界上最糟糕的事情。据胡安·伊格纳西奥·塞雷达说，社区威胁要绝食，因为公寓楼会极大地限制他们的生活。
Sure, they were living in a slum before, but at least they had control over their own space. They could make expansions and adjustments when they wanted to. But with a block style housing project, they'd be confined to a small, static space. Which is worse because you're not able to expand the house. And so what Elmentall came up with were tall, rectangular houses separated by empty space. Each unit was just big enough to meet Chile's minimum standards for low-income housing. And then the residents could, on their own time, however they wanted, expand into the empty space adjacent to their home.
当然，他们以前住在贫民窟，但至少他们能控制自己的空间。他们可以在需要时进行扩建和调整。但如果是公寓式的住房项目，他们就会被限制在一个狭小、静态的空间里。这更糟糕，因为你无法扩建房子。于是，Elemental想出了高大的矩形房屋，中间由空地隔开。每个单元的大小刚好满足智利低收入住房的最低标准。然后，居民可以在自己的时间里，以他们想要的任何方式，向房子旁边的空地进行扩建。
Element Hall spent the early 2000s iterating on this concept, building homes that just met the basic legal requirements for low income housing in Chile, but with room to grow. And then in 2012, after the earthquake in Constitution, Elemental got a commission to help create a new master plan for the city, which included creating a new neighborhood full of incremental buildings. It would be located on one of the tallest hills in the city and would be called Via Verde. Okay, we are on our way up to Via Verde and Constitución. Oh wow, here it is. This is it right here. Wow, it's really big. The same went out to see Via Verde with producer Martina Castro. Yes, we drive around. Yeah. To get to Viva Verde, you drive straight up one of the tallest hills in
Elemental在21世纪初不断迭代这一概念，建造的房屋刚好满足智利低收入住房的基本法律要求，但留有增长空间。2012年，在孔斯蒂图西翁地震后，Elemental接到委托，帮助为该市制定新的总体规划，其中包括创建一个充满增量建筑的新社区。它将位于该市最高的山丘之一，被称为“绿色之路”（Via Verde）。好的，我们正在前往孔斯蒂图西翁“绿色之路”的路上。哦哇，就在这儿。就是这儿。哇，它真的很大。我带着制片人玛蒂娜·卡斯特罗去看了“绿色之路”。是的，我们开车四处转转。是的。要到达“绿色之路”，你得直接开上
Constitution. You pass a traditional looking apartment complex, also built to house people after the 2010 quake. Once you're on top of the hill, you get some just staggering views of the town, the ocean, and the river Maule below. It's like a whole bunch of these little boxes on a hillside. Looking over, that's the river Maule. Viva Verde is made of neat rows of simple two-story houses. Half of each house is identical. Same windows, same color, kind of a farmhouse red.
孔斯蒂图西翁最高的山丘之一。你会经过一个看起来很传统的公寓大楼，也是为了在2010年地震后安置人们而建的。一旦你到了山顶，你就能看到城镇、海洋和下方莫莱河的惊人景色。就像山坡上的一堆小盒子。看那边，那是莫莱河。“绿色之路”由整齐的简单两层房屋组成。每栋房子的一半都是一样的。同样的窗户，同样的颜色，一种农舍红。
The other half of each house, though, is completely different. They have different doors, different windows, or pieces of tarp, or windows will go. And in some houses, half the house has nothing there at all. It's just like half the house is missing. And then there are plenty of houses that people built out. When people get their houses, the side that comes pre-built is pretty bare bones. The walls are unpainted sheet rock, and the floors are unfinished concrete and plywood. The kitchen comes with just a sink, no stove, no refrigerator, no cabinets.
不过，每栋房子的另一半则完全不同。它们有不同的门、不同的窗户，或者用防水布遮挡，或者窗户该在的地方。有些房子，半边房子什么都没有。就像半边房子不见了一样。然后还有很多房子是人们自己扩建出来的。当人们拿到房子时，预建的那一侧非常简陋。墙壁是未刷漆的石膏板，地板是未完工的混凝土和胶合板。厨房里只有一个水槽，没有炉灶，没有冰箱，没有橱柜。
The houses are spartan, to say the least, but they are habitable, practical and well insulated. Martina Castro and I spent a couple of days walking around Vio Verde, talking to residents, and it's there that we met Luis and Ríquez, the earthquake survivor we heard from earlier. We're in a radio program in the United States. Can we pass? Yes, we can. When we met him, Luis and his wife were outside,
这些房子至少可以说是简朴的，但它们适合居住、实用且隔热良好。玛蒂娜·卡斯特罗和我花了几天时间在“绿色之路”走访，与居民交谈，在那里我们遇到了路易斯·恩里克斯，我们之前听到的那位地震幸存者。我们是美国的一个广播节目。我们可以进去吗？是的，可以。当我们见到他时，路易斯和他的妻子正在外面，
working on a gravel walkway to their home. Luis invited us in, Martina translates. So when you moved in, what were the most important things that you wanted to do right away? When they moved in, what were the most important things that you wanted to do right away? With help from his wife and his brother who also lives in Viva Verde, the Wies laid concrete on the empty side of the house to make a floor and put up exterior walls and flooring for the second story. None of them had really done construction before, but they had direction from workshops on
铺设通往他们家的碎石路。路易斯邀请我们进去，玛蒂娜担任翻译。那么当你搬进来时，你最想立刻做的事情是什么？当他们搬进来时，他们最想立刻做的事情是什么？在妻子和也住在“绿色之路”的兄弟的帮助下，路易斯在房子的空侧铺设了混凝土作为地板，并为二楼搭建了外墙和地板。他们之前都没有真正做过建筑工作，但他们得到了Elemental协助举办的建筑技术研讨会的指导。
building techniques that Elemental helped facilitate. The homes also come with a user manual, with directions for how to expand the house, and expansions can be done with standard-sized building materials. So residents don't have to pay lots of money for a custom cut pieces of lumber. So far, Luis has focused his efforts on just getting the house to be big enough to accommodate his family. And so inside, the walls are still unpainted. The downstairs floors are still just unfinished concrete
这些房屋还附带一本用户手册，说明如何扩建房屋，而且扩建可以使用标准尺寸的建筑材料。所以居民不必花很多钱去买定制切割的木材。到目前为止，路易斯专注于让房子变得足够大以容纳他的家人。所以房子里面，墙壁仍然没有刷漆。楼下的地板仍然只是未完工的混凝土，
and upstairs it's unfinished plywood. Luis knows they've got a long way to go on their home. But he doesn't just see the bare walls and coarse floor. He sees what it all can become. If and when the Enrique's family does have tiling and carpet and paint and baseboard on the walls, it'll be way nicer than anything that they ever could have afforded on their own,
楼上是未完工的胶合板。路易斯知道他们的家还有很长的路要走。但他看到的不仅仅是裸露的墙壁和粗糙的地板。他看到了这一切未来可能的样子。如果恩里克斯一家铺上瓷砖、地毯、刷上油漆并装上踢脚线，它将比他们自己能负担得起的任何东西都要好得多，
or what they could have normally gotten through state-funded low-income housing programs. And so now, Luis is the owner of a four-bedroom home that keeps out the cold, won't get flooded, and won't fall down in an earthquake. You know, my wife and I, we've had tough lives. So finding out that we were going to be owners of our own house was just incredible. Not everyone I talked to at Viva Verde was enthusiastic about having to build their own home, and some thought elementals contractors
或者比他们通常通过国家资助的低收入住房计划所能得到的要好。所以现在，路易斯拥有一栋四居室的房子，它能挡风遮雨，不会被淹，也不会在地震中倒塌。你知道，我和我妻子，我们过得很艰难。所以发现我们将成为自己房子的主人，真是太不可思议了。并不是我在“绿色之路”交谈过的每个人都对必须自己盖房子感到兴奋，有些人认为Elemental的承包商
could have done a better job. But for the most part, people there seemed really happy with their homes. Even people who hadn't expanded theirs at all. One resident, a single mom named Camila Hernandez, Rodriguez, hadn't made any additions yet. I can't wait for the new one. Yeah, so of course, you know, one dream.
本可以做得更好。但大多数人似乎对他们的房子非常满意。即使是那些根本没有扩建的人也是如此。一位居民，单身母亲卡米拉·埃尔南德斯·罗德里格斯，还没有做任何加建。我等不及要建新的了。是的，当然，你知道，一个梦想。
And you think that you're going to just have everything ready all all at once. And so I wanted to build out the house and everything. But then I just focused on doing small things first because obviously I couldn't do that right away. Most people in Vivaverde are further along with their expansions than Camila. And everyone seems to have some project or another. Some residents have even opted to use their extra space to start businesses, like little stores that sell bread and candy and cell phone minutes.
你以为你会一下子拥有一切准备就绪的东西。所以我想要扩建房子等等。但后来我专注于先做一些小事，因为显然我不能立刻做到那些。在“绿色之路”，大多数人在扩建方面比卡米拉进展得更远。每个人似乎都有这样或那样的项目。一些居民甚至选择利用他们额外的空间来创业，比如卖面包、糖果和手机充值卡的小商店。
The feeling I got from residents is that they felt invested in Viva Verde. They like living there and they felt safe. It all kinda made me wonder, why haven't we seen this approach in the US? I don't think this could work in the US. There's a lot of things going on here, which are really innovative,
我从居民那里得到的感觉是，他们对“绿色之路”有投入感。他们喜欢住在那里，并且感到安全。这一切让我不禁想问，为什么我们在美国没有看到这种方法？我不认为这在美国行得通。这里发生了很多事情，确实非常创新，
and there's a lot of things where things go wrong. This is Dr. Jennifer Stoloff, a researcher with the consulting firm, Econometrica. Before that, I was a social science analyst at HUD in the Office of Policy Development and Research for about 14 years. Dr. Stoloff is an expert
也有很多事情出了问题。这是詹妮弗·斯托洛夫博士，咨询公司Econometrica的研究员。在此之前，我在住房和城市发展部（HUD）的政策发展与研究办公室担任社会科学分析师约14年。斯托洛夫博士是评估政府项目，特别是与住房相关项目的专家。
at evaluating government programs, particularly those that pertain to housing. She's also an historian of public housing in the US. I told Dr. Stolloff about the V.A. Verde project and send her some pictures, and she says, yeah, it does kind of align with the US ethos of pulling yourself up by your bootstraps. It is very bootstrappy, it's true.
她也是美国公共住房的历史学家。我告诉了斯托洛夫博士关于“绿色之路”项目的情况，并给她发了一些照片，她说，是的，这确实有点符合美国“白手起家”的精神。这确实非常“白手起家”。
But it's also very risky. I mean, and I mean in a safety way, not just in a financial way. It is very bootstrappy, it's true, but it's also very risky. I mean, and I mean in a safety way, not just in a financial way. It is both. First off, someone could get hurt building out their house, which means you would have to deal with both a medical and a legal emergency. In the States, you know, there'd be litigation issues, right? I mean, if you were working building your floor or ceiling and you fell down in the states, maybe you would sue the developer.
但它也非常冒险。我是说，在安全方面，不仅仅是在财务方面。这确实非常“白手起家”，但它也非常冒险。我是说，在安全方面，不仅仅是在财务方面。两者皆有。首先，有人在扩建房子时可能会受伤，这意味着你必须同时处理医疗和法律紧急情况。在美国，你知道，会有诉讼问题，对吧？我是说，如果你在建造地板或天花板时摔倒了，在美国，也许你会起诉开发商。
But for Dr. Stoloff, the biggest hurdle to an incremental building project working in the US isn't a matter of safety or legality. It would be an embarrassment, right? So the United States of America can only build poor people half a house? We'd be ashamed of ourselves. Even though in fact that might end up providing way more people with adequate housing at the end of the day. But we couldn't do it. It's like we'd lose face. Because unlike Chile, the United States does have the money. And perhaps also unlike Chile. We don't like to spend money on poor people. We don't like to spend money on poor people. We think everybody should be able to find their own way out of poverty. And it's just not true, but that is the expectation. And we are not in a scarcity economy, and we could afford to give people an entire house.
但对斯托洛夫博士来说，增量建筑项目在美国运作的最大障碍不是安全或法律问题。那会很尴尬，对吧？所以美利坚合众国只能给穷人盖半套房子？我们会为自己感到羞耻。尽管事实上，这最终可能会为更多人提供充足的住房。但我们做不到。就像我们会丢脸一样。因为与智利不同，美国确实有钱。也许也与智利不同，我们不喜欢在穷人身上花钱。我们不喜欢在穷人身上花钱。我们认为每个人都应该能够找到自己的脱贫之路。这根本不是事实，但这就是期望。我们不是处于稀缺经济中，我们完全负担得起给人们一整套房子。
But by large, we don't. For the US, it's not a matter of scarcity. It's a matter of values. Elemental, however, has come to see scarcity as a tool. A tool which Juan Ignacio Serra finds vital. I'm sure that in the States, everything have rules and controls, so you don't leave room to all those new things that came up from the letting world.
但总的来说，我们没有这样做。对美国来说，这不是稀缺的问题。这是价值观的问题。然而，Elemental已经开始将稀缺视为一种工具。一种胡安·伊格纳西奥·塞雷达认为至关重要的工具。我相信在美国，一切都有规则和控制，所以你没有空间去尝试那些从发展中国家产生的新事物。
That obviously comes from disgusting. So if you were doing this project in Constitio Cion and let's just say at the very last minute they go, okay we're going to double your budget. Would you would you then have made everyone full houses? I don't know. That's having to happen. Theoretically, the money wasn't a restraint which you still want to build the way you do. It's a good thing to deliver a whole house, but if you give me the devil the money, I keep the houses at risk, and I improve with all that money, the public space surrounding
这显然来自……（音频不清晰）。所以如果你在孔斯蒂图西翁做这个项目，假设在最后一刻他们说，好吧，我们要把你的预算翻倍。你会给每个人盖完整的房子吗？我不知道。这还没发生过。理论上，如果钱不是限制，你还会按照你现在的方式建造吗？交付一整套房子是件好事，但如果你给我双倍的钱，我会保持房子的结构，并用所有的钱改善房子周围的公共空间，
the house, that neighborhood. Providing the infrastructure that people can't provide themselves, like parks and libraries and public transit, is at the very root of the sites and services approach. Building half a house might be the best way to make a community whole. 99% invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan with Katie Mingle, Sherefuse, have Kurt Colstead, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me, Roman Mars. Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazda, Delaney Hall, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Austin McCann, Carla Palma, Martina Castro, Dave Humphrey,
那个社区。提供人们自己无法提供的基础设施，如公园、图书馆和公共交通，正是“选址与服务”方法的根本所在。建造半套房子可能是让社区变得完整的最好方式。《99%隐形》本周由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔、谢雷·福斯、库尔特·科尔斯特德、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰伦·马扎、德莱尼·霍尔和我，罗曼·马尔斯共同参与。
Salonpe Bernal, Marcella Espinoza, Ricardo Sugundo Kiero Valdez, Maria Antonieta, Bianchi Diaz, Christian Martinez, and Francesca Moroni. And special thanks to Okikumi, who's chill music. You are listening to right now. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California.
本周特别感谢奥斯汀·麦肯、卡拉·帕尔马、玛蒂娜·卡斯特罗、戴夫·汉弗莱、萨隆佩·伯纳尔、马塞拉·埃斯皮诺萨、里卡多·苏贡多·基耶罗·瓦尔德斯、玛丽亚·安东尼埃塔·比安奇·迪亚兹、克里斯蒂安·马丁内斯和弗朗西斯卡·莫罗尼。还要特别感谢奥基库米，你现在听到的就是他那令人放松的音乐。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心广播街制作。
You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% invisible you must go to 99pi.org Radio topi from PRX Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括很酷的照片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Topi来自PRX。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。